viaggiando in giro per il mondo e
incontrando le persone spesso sono
accolto insieme al team al quale ho la
fortuna di fare parte con grande
entusiasmo delle con le frasi del tipo
ma è straordinario quello che state
facendo
ma che bello ma voi veramente cambiate
il mondo e poi quasi sempre la domanda
perché lo fai
sì perché le nostre vite sono
essenzialmente una sequenza di eventi ai
quali spesso chiediamo il perché e io
credo che questa è una domanda
fondamentale nato in brasile in un circo
i miei genitori naturali erano una
veterinaria brasiliana e un domatore di
leone di origini napoletane
credetemi
in quegli anni mi chiedevo come mai
fosse nato in una famiglia diciamo
peculiari anni dopo
per fondate ragioni quando l'assistenza
sociale intervenire e di cd e decide di
allontanare mio fratello ed io dalla sua
famiglia per affidarci a non fanno
trofeo mi sono chiesto perché di questo
cambio di circostanze all'età di 10 anni
quando una coppia senza figli decise di
adottare questi due bambini e dare loro
una nuova opportunità di vita
mi chiesi perché questo colpo di fortuna
all'età di 26 anni quando mio fratello
muore in un ospedale proprio di fronte
alla sua nuova famiglia
ancora una volta mi chiesi perché di
questa tragedia
i perché cambiano la nostra vita
e credetemi perché possono cambiare
anche il mondo e io questo l'ho scoperto
proprio in questo momento con il mio
amico
guardavo il mare e apprezzava una bella
giornata di sole
io ho capito in quel momento ho preso
coscienza che noi viviamo in un pianeta
la cui superficie è coperta per il 70
per cento da acqua e sopra le nostre
teste brilla una fonte di energia
illimitata pulita e gratuita quindi di
fronte a queste risorse limitate mi sono
detto perché un miliardo di persone oggi
non hanno accesso all'acqua potabile
sono cinquemila persone che muoiono ogni
anno per il fatto di bere acqua
contaminata quasi 2 milioni all'anno
eppure le nazioni unite hanno dichiarato
questo
l'acqua un diritto umano fondamentale
quindi noi stiamo violando se è
essenzialmente un diritto umano nel
momento nel quale non diamo acqua ai
popoli senza poi contare il fatto che
due miliardi di persone non ha ancora
accesso al l'elettricità quindi vivono
sostanzialmente come i nostri antenati
vivevano secoli fa e vogliamo parlare
dei 5 miliardi di persone che sono
completamente ti sconnessi
dall'educazione dall'informazione non
appartengono al secolo ventuno colmare
il divario che esiste tra noi e i
miliardi di persone che abbiamo lasciato
dietro di noi rappresenta una sfida la
sfida più importante socialmente
economicamente dei prossimi vent'anni
nel prossimo secolo
essenzialmente non possiamo però pensare
di creare un benessere a livello
mondiale
usando quelle stesse tecnologie che
hanno creato il nostro di benessere
perché queste tecnologie in parte stanno
distruggendo il nostro pianeta stanno
creando conflitti fra i popoli e stanno
probabilmente anche decidendo la fine
della nostra civilizzazione le più
grandi sfide a livello mondiale solo
quelle che richiedono i più grandi
cambiamenti
quindi noi dobbiamo pensare a un nuovo
paradigma ma sapete la bella notizia è
che lo stiamo già facendo
noi stiamo costruendo macchine che
funzionano con energia solare possono
essere installate in pochi giorni in
qualunque parte del mondo
queste macchine queste tecnologie sono
capaci di purificare l'acqua solo con la
forza del sole da qualunque tipo di
contaminazione sia essa fisica
batteriologica e chimica desalinizzare
l'acqua del mare puliscono l'acqua dei
stanno dei pozzi dall'arsenico dai
metalli pesanti dal puro qualunque
sostanza sono anche capaci di generare
elettricità fuori dalla rete e sono dei
computer che permettono un sistema di
telecomunicazione avanzato in tutto il
mondo una macchina come questa impatta
positivamente una comunità di tremila
persone però migliaia di macchine come
questa possono impattare l'anno umanità
beneficiando il pianeta terra
queste macchine assieme creano la
cosiddetta energy net che cos'è la
energymed da energy nette sono macchine
scalabili intelligenti versatili
connesse tra di loro si comportano come
dei computer quindi scambiano dati
informazioni ma qui internet si fonde
con il concetto di acqua e di
elettricità questa è la reale internet
delle cose dove non ci sono cose e dove
non c'è ancora internet
questa è la più grande rivoluzione
tecnologica dei prossimi vent'anni e le
macchine che sono infrastrutturali a
questa struttura assomigliano proprio a
questa questo è il primo computer
termodinamico del mondo e si sta
costruendo in italia
ovviamente rappresenta il risultato
finale di 3 anni di duro lavoro da parte
di un team dedicato un team che non ha
mai accettato l'idea che certe cose non
si potessero fare è sicuramente non ho
si dovessero fare sono macchine capaci
di essere sviluppate con un processo
intermedio noi le abbiamo provate le
abbiamo costruite le abbiamo testate le
abbiamo portate anche nel cuore del
problema in africa e credetemi abbiamo
visto con i nostri occhi che cosa vuol
dire portare il xxi secolo
a questi popoli liberarli permetterà
loro di accedere alla vita accedere
all'energia di cui hanno bisogno
ma ancora più importante accedere al
loro futuro
durante questo cammino quello che io
personalmente ho capito che queste
tecnologie non ci fanno più ricchi o più
potenti queste tecnologie liberano i
popoli che danno loro la pace io ho
capito nel corso di questi anni che ciò
che facciamo
cambia il mondo per un momento ma il
perché lo facciamo può cambiare il mondo
per sempre se cerchiamo dentro di noi il
perché della nostra vita
creeremo fuori di noi
il cambiamento che abbiamo sempre
desiderato
grazie della vostra attenzione